remember when Donald Trump at a press
conference suggested that Russia find
Hillary Clinton's supposedly missing
supposedly 30,000 emails I want to
refresh your memory about that moment
from July of 2016
Russia if you're listening I hope you're
able to find the 30,000 emails that are
missing I think you will probably be
rewarded mightily by our press in
retrospect we now recognize the absolute
insanity of Donald Trump's ERCOT request
and when Trump did it it exploded it was
the appearance that he was calling on a
foreign country to commit crimes and the
Trump campaign at the time made an
effort to say it's a joke it's obviously
a joke it's not something he was serious
about well it's now been revealed that
the same night right hours after Donald
Trump said what I just played for you
Russian operatives Russian intelligence
officers attempted to do exactly what
Donald Trump suggested that they do get
access to Hillary Clinton's email
according to this latest Robert Moeller
indictment of 12 more Russians and to be
extra clear not random people who happen
to be in Russia according to the
indictments these were Russian
intelligence agents and there are
actually two different interpretations
here the initial interpretation a lot of
people had when they learned that Trump
asked Russia to do the hacking and hours
later Russia did it that the sort of
obvious interpretation was well Russia
heard Trump's request and then they went
ahead and did it and tried to hack
Hillary Clinton's emails that one is not
actually as plausible to me as the idea
that when Trump said this he already
knew that Russian intelligence was
working on and going to try to hack
Hillary Clinton's emails so when Trump
said it it wasn't actually what caused
Russia to do it he said it knowing that
it was something Russia was already
planning to do in the either case it's
even more evidence that WikiLeaks is
either compromised by or in cahoots with
Russia which we mostly already knew
because of the connection to goose' fur
Gucci fur however you pronounce it 2.0
yeah and now when we look back at that
conference it just looks very brazen
right like why would Donald Trump make
that request in public but the Russia
hysteria hadn't started yet so that's
why he thought he could get away with
such a car by hysteria you don't mean
unwarranted hysteria you mean before the
scandal started legitimate about I think
that's what you meet anyway geez all of
a sudden Pat's jumping on the skeptic
train with Russia but also what does
that thing mean where Trump says that
the American press would reward them
greatly
like how how would the American press
reward individual Russian intelligence I
don't even know what he means by that
when he said that very odd just that
would be a big story I guess because
they would have so much to dig through
all those emails maybe I don't even know
here's an idea at some point there's
going to be a second stage of this
entire Russian operation and Russia will
go completely hostile to trump like at
today's press conference with Trump and
Putin it was just heaping praise on each
other and throwing bouquets back and
forth and everybody's just so great
other than the FBI and Democrats of
course they're terrible I suspect that
because Putin's goal is to sow chaos and
to embolden the perception of Russia as
a powerful actor on the world stage
Putin is going to play friendly with
Trump for as long as that's useful and
eventually Putin might completely throw
Trump under the bus I don't know why but
I'm getting the sense that this is only
gonna last so long I don't know I don't
know we're altima Lee going to have to
wait and see
as far as Trump goading Russia
requesting that Russia hack Hillary
imagine for a moment if Obama has said
to some other hostile country pick
whatever country you want right hey
Yemen if you can find Trump's tax
returns do it and you're going to be
greatly rewarded by our press you would
have right-wing media calling for
Obama's head I mean they called for his
head for wearing a tan suit imagine if
he suggested Yemen hack Trump's tax
returns but hypocrisy no longer matters
consistency is irrelevant unless I guess
you're you're not a committed Trump
estat this point and the double standard
is truly truly stunning today's program
is sponsored in part by foo tour the
tour is
social forecasting game where players
come together and compete with each
other to predict future events you open
up the game on your phone or web browser
you'll see a whole range of forecasts
covering topics across the board
politics sports so much more you wager
on predictions about real world events
using food tours in game fake currency
and you earn more of this currency every
time you make a prediction that comes
true you can show off your prediction
skills to friends improve your
forecasting ability I'm even on futur
you can find my account by clicking the
link in the description if you're
watching this on YouTube
this week on future I pose the question
will the US Senate confirm Brett
Kavanaugh for Supreme Court what do you
think click the link in the description
and place your bets and you can sign up
now at Foote or calm and start making
your forecasts on political topics and
so many other topics it's free and it's
available on both Android and iOS as
well as on web browsers
that's fut you you are calm